I've spent the last 25 years
as a brand architect,
helping brands rise, thrive and conquer.
Yet it struck me like a lightning
bolt the other day
when I had a realization
that left me feeling uneasy.
Have I been helping brands
destroy the world?
Don't get me wrong,
I've had the privilege to craft
and see the power of creativity
shape minds and win hearts.
It's an exciting job.
But looking at the state
of the world today,
could the influence industry
of advertising and PR be harming people,
influencing wrong behaviors,
encouraging a world
of excessive consumerism
which as a result has led
to overconsumption,
environmental degradation,
deaths and a shallow fixation
on material possessions?
The thing about advertising
and PR is that it can be sneaky.
You know, it's like that one friend
who brings both chocolate cupcakes
and kale salad to the party.
One minute, we charm consumers
with catchy jingles
and hilarious commercials,
and the next, we're bombarding them
with messages for things they don't need.
It's impossible not to notice
an advertising and PR industry
that is directly and indirectly
nudging the world
toward ecological collapse.
And I must say, even just saying that
feels like a punch in the gut
for someone immersed in the world
of advertising and PR.
So I can imagine my fellow industry peers
looking at me right now thinking,
"Dude, what the hell?"
But we must admit,
the world is going through a spectacle
of epic proportions.
You know, from energy supply crisis
to food supply crisis,
rising inflation, etc. etc.
It's like the headlines
of a blockbuster movie,
only this time it's real life,
and it's happening in my own life.
I live in Johannesburg,
where our electricity supply gets cut off
due to load shedding,
you know, resulting in hours
and hours of daily power cuts.
When load shedding
was initially introduced,
it shocked everyone.
Just the idea of facing
such a severe power shortage
and its profound impact on our lives
was completely unimaginable.
Something that we never thought
would happen is actually happening.
Climate change is no joke,
and you know things are getting real
when you see snow in Johannesburg.
You know, it's like Mother Nature
is playing a prank on us.
I live and work in the most unequal
country on the planet,
with acute inequality being our reality.
So you can only imagine then,
how critical the messages
that we put out in advertising and PR
can be within this context.
So this is kind of personal for me.
And to be honest,
these issues are not only happening
in Johannesburg, South Africa.
We are seeing these issues
happen everywhere else around the world.
But here's the tension.
To tackle overconsumption,
we seriously have to reduce
what we consume
and how much we consume.
And of course, the irony for me
and my 391-billion-dollar industry
is that our day-to-day jobs
require us to impel everyone
to buy, buy, buy and buy.
So as a result,
we have created a "mess-terpiece,"
you know, a mess,
using our influence to drive
excessive consumerism.
So how then, do we,
as an advertising and PR industry,
atone for our missteps?
I wish there was a pill we could take
and then -- poof -- problem solved.
But this is not going to be
the easiest thing to do.
How do we tell our clients
that we need to sell less
when all they want from us is to move
tons and tons of products off the shelves?
Should we reconsider or consider
not advertising ever?
I mean, this sounds
a little bit bonkers, right?
But it is indeed a massive undertaking.
But the gift of creativity
is our tool for change.
We can use this tool
to fight excessive consumerism
and make a huge difference.
And it all starts with the Honesty Squad.
The thing is, if we can convince
people to buy more,
we can convince people to buy less,
to buy differently or to buy responsibly.
So imagine every advertising
and PR agency struts its stuff
with the Honesty Squad,
meticulously scrutinizing campaigns
not only from a creative perspective
or from a, I suppose,
strategic perspective,
but also from an
environmental perspective.
So the Honesty Squad
presents a paradigm shift
in how we operate as an industry
by placing particular emphasis
on stopping excessive consumerism.
So imagine what the possibilities
could be with this.
An industry that is all about making
people think twice before they buy.
An industry making stuff
that doesn't trash the planet.
An industry saying no
to throwaway culture.
We're talking about changing
how individuals shop.
Getting governments to make better rules
and getting industries to be eco-friendly.
So to be an industry
with the superpower of conscious.
So what will the Honesty
Squad do exactly?
On a glaringly obvious level,
we would stop advocating
and sanitizing for oil companies.
True.
(Applause)
According to Adweek, nearly 300 agencies
and six major holding companies
are currently servicing
fossil fuel clients,
and it's hard to ignore that the situation
seems quite irrational, right,
in light of the severe climate change
impacts that we're witnessing today.
But anyway, my team and I decided
to kind of have a bit of fun.
And so we put together some
ad samples, some examples,
just to showcase how
the Honesty Squad could tackle
some of the challenges
that we have to face.
So look at this example.
"Of course, we want you
to eat our burger ...
But try our plant-based option.
It's yummy."
Here's the thing.
Excessive meat consumption
harms the planet,
and that's because many people
are unaware of this fact.
And as an advertising and PR industry,
we haven't done enough to showcase
alternatives which are better
for the planet.
And we definitely need
to just change that.
Simple, right?
Look at this next example.
"If you make these jeans your new BFF,
your old pair gets a new home.
Deal?"
This is really all about making sure that
we encourage people to give away stuff
they don't use,
because we cannot
be sending stuff to landfills
time and time again.
Are you with me?
Right.
"Keeping up with the Joneses again?"
This is the next example.
"Stop it already."
We seriously have
to challenge this culture
where people are constantly
being encouraged
to consume stuff and to buy stuff
in order for them to look
successful or to look happy.
And this intense pressure
we put on consumers
to keep up with the Joneses
and live lives they don't afford
is really, really not necessary.
We've got to just stop that.
The next example,
"We could tell you that this drink
will make you look cool and stuff,
but we would be lying.
It just tastes good, you know, full stop."
So many people consume stuff
in order to showcase
a certain image on social media.
I mean, we really, definitely need
to just change that, right?
The last example,
"Three for two sounds good,
but do you really need 50 tubs
of hand lotion all at once?"
Like, come on, right?
So you could imagine
the Honesty Squad then
as your kind of personal
wingman, you know,
helping you, you know, stay away
from unnecessary shopping.
And I think many of us would definitely
benefit from that, right?
So you can see that there are
a lot of opportunities,
from a creative perspective,
for us to do some really good
work and change that.
But the other thing that excites me
about my industry,
and we know this very well,
is that we appreciate
a fabulous pat on the back.
And creative awards actually
do that, you know?
So let's celebrate then campaigns
that reduce waste,
you know, campaigns that encourage
mindful shopping,
you know, campaigns that reduce or rather,
you know, recycle old products for reuse,
like this exciting campaign by Ikea.
In Norway alone,
over three million pieces of furniture
are thrown away each year.
Three million.
And for Ikea to deal with this problem,
they decided to collect
all old Ikea furniture
and actually sell it,
utilizing the reasons why
they were no longer needed.
So reasons like breakups,
divorce, you know, etc.
So what Ikea did was effectively
take the old furniture
and resell it to new customers
in their stores.
How cool is that?
This is exactly how
the Honesty Squad rolls,
and I think we need to be doing
a lot more of that as an industry.
So it is loud and clear
everywhere around the world
that we cannot continue going
the way we've been going.
And as an industry,
we cannot be tone deaf in a world
that is screaming for a refresh.
And of course, all those
negative ninjas out there will say,
"This will never work.
This can never happen."
But can you imagine if it did?
Think about it.
Not so long ago,
we used to advertise
cigarettes unashamedly.
Now we don't.
So these changes could seriously
change the way we live.
But what excites me more about all of this
is that creativity can really
solve these problems,
and do so on a large scale.
So let's leverage our core
strengths of creativity and influence
to tackle some of the challenges
that we are facing
as a global community.
But to do that,
we'd have to be really honest
about the impacts
that our advertising and PR is having
on our planet and on our people.
I believe it's not impossible,
even though I may have had an utterly
horrifying realization about what I do
as an agency owner
and as a brand architect,
I do see the immediate opportunity
for us to channel this gift of creativity
of our industry into a powerful ally.
Because, you know, as consumerism
reaches unprecedented levels
and the climate crisis intensifies,
our role as the advertising
and PR industry
can be that pivotal intervention
that the world needs right now.
So let's embrace
this responsibility, my friends,
which is really all about making right
for the brands that we represent,
but also doing right for the planet
and for its people.
Let's do that.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)